je rebondis revue qu'on parle du conseil
d'état sur le fait que le conseil d'état
à plusieurs reprises mais je vais penser
surtout à cette question du 1er février
2010 9 avait été saisi du retrait du lb
départ un certain nombre d'associations
qui s'étaient mobilisés contre les
usages du ldd et les conseils d'état a
répondu de la façon de très claires
selon laquelle l'usagé de ce moyen de
défense est strictement encadrée et
qu'il est rendu nécessaire par
l'existence de violences ou d'atteintes
aux biens
c'est ça la réalité c'est la réalité
presque chaque jour chaque nuit où il en
est fait usage dans notre pays par nos
forces de sécurité à l'intérieur dans
des moments de tensions extrêmement fort
qu'ils vivent
hélas au quotidien et malgré ces
tensions qui ne font qu'augmenter nous
disions au début nos propos je vous
rappelle que l'usagé du ldd a beaucoup
baissé en 2010 9 - 43% de tir en france
sur l'usagé du lb et en matière de
gestion de l'ordre public j'ai très tôt
demandé que les tirs sauf circonstances
exceptionnelles notamment liées à
légitime défense
les tirs de l bd soit systématiquement
filmé il y à une doctrine différente
tantôt gendarmerie et police nationale
nous sommes en train de travailler sur
ce sujet il me paraît important qu'on
ait une dicte rien partager je défends
lusage duel bd pour nos forces de
sécurité intérieure parce que je sais
qu'elles ont formés pour se sont formés
pour et je sais qu'elles savent aussi
l'utiliser dans un cadre strictement
nécessaire immédiat est proportionnée il
peut arriver qu'il y ait des fautes
ces fautes doivent ouvrir à des
contrôles doivent ouvrir des enquêtes
sur nos anges judiciaire et il peut y
avoir des décisions je discerne prononce
évidemment pas sur ce sujet là ce qui
compte c'est d'avoir le bon équipement
et la bonne formation